nearly one in four young people in
Europe are unemployed and charities are
warning that with the economic crisis a
whole generation may take years to get
their foot on the ladder the parliaments
president agrees now is not a good time
to be young my life was really better
than the life of my parents my chances
were bigger than the chances of my
parents and now we are living in a
situation that be as European
institutions are asking sacrifices from
people in the countries for banks not
for their children
the European Parliament invited two
young people one with and one without a
job from each country to attend a forum
to discuss how to solve the problem over
the course of three days in Brussels the
debate couldn't avoid talk of the crisis
I did feel the need as a young German in
solidarity with other Europeans who are
unemployed to point out that of course
part of the issue of youth unemployment
is the macroeconomic situation and the
austerity measures that we are
responsible for we still have a chance
to address this and possibly to change
our course we had a very interesting
discussion about economy about the
relationship between Germany and Europe
Germany and the countries that are being
bailed out and it's so useful and so
helpful to actually speak with person of
that nationality with like a German
person after much deliberation the group
produced a series of recommendations for
the MEP s which included giving a small
percentage of the youth employment
initiative money to the young people
themselves to run programs you know sort
of V in rosada VA el parque de journee
pas de Jonge totoko cermony politics ROP
any national kyoto and so i didn't come
more clear limits Priscilla knows HEPA
avoir via tadka hot bath wash wash octo
saw the journal topic picked presidents
shorts we'll take the conclusions to a
meeting of EU leaders in Paris on
November 12th MEP s themselves will have
to take heed as if nothing is done to
reverse current trends it could have
huge repercussions for the whole of
society